i must give the british people a very
simple
instruction you must stay at home
he said he hopes never to issue that
instruction again
but in order to avoid another full
national lockdown
new national restrictions are once again
being imposed
in response to rising cases the latest
step
making self-isolation a legal
requirement in england
enforceable with fines of up to ten
thousand pounds
in a statement the prime minister said
the best way we can fight this virus is
by everyone following the rules and
self-isolating if they're at risk of
passing on coronavirus
and so nobody underestimates just how
important this
is new regulations will mean you are
legally obliged to do so
if you have the virus or have been asked
to do so by nhs test and trace
people who choose to ignore the rules
will face significant fines
to assist those facing financial
pressures the government has also
announced a self-isolation payment of
500 pounds
for those on low incomes but some in the
scientific community
have warned it's not just an issue of
compliance they say more effective
testing and tracing
should be a priority the question is you
know are we going to keep doing this and
keep seeing these peaks
until such point as we have a roll out
of a nationwide vaccine
i hope not but the only way we can do
that is through making sure we have the
mechanisms and tools in place
to be able to stop that and that is a
functioning testing system
and a functioning contact racing system
the government have made clear the
outright closure of schools and
businesses would be a last resort
but consideration is being given to the
national rollout
of measures already in place in local
hotspots these include bans on
socializing outside of your own
household
and restrictions on pubs and restaurants
that would see them close at 10 pm
labour say the government need to show
some urgency in coming to a decision
at the start of this pandemic earlier in
the year the government were
too slow they were slow to lock down
they were slow on personal protective
equipment
slow on testing and i'm afraid they
still haven't got
test track and isolate anywhere near the
level that it should be
so what we're saying to the government
is don't be
slow again new local restrictions for
parts of the northeast have just taken
effect in blyth
some here who switched their vote from
labour to the conservatives at the last
election
are now regretting that decision thought
they were brilliant mushy soon i thought
they were brilliant but then
as time's gone on we don't know we don't
think they know what they do i don't
like the man now but there you go
but others were more forgiving i think
he has a very difficult task
very difficult and i don't think anyone
else in his position could have done any
better
back in westminster it's not clear all
conservative mps will show the same
patience
it's less than a week since the rule of
six was introduced across the country
and the prime minister is already
considering whether he needs to go
further but as part of that calculation
he'll be aware that there are those in
his party who believe the
current restrictions already go too far
and are planning a potential
parliamentary challenge to the existing
rules
in the coming days for a prime minister
keen to show he's guided by the science
that will further complicate his options
doing too little
or too much could both come at a
considerable cost
tom rayner sky news westminster